the world's last trillion-dollar
industry was created out of computer
code the world's next trillion dollar
industry is going to be created out of a
genetic code our bodies are made up of
about 25,000 genes and the first human
genome was mapped about 15 years ago it
was done so over a period of about a
decade and at a cost of 2.7 billion
dollars just five years ago Steve Jobs
was one of 10 people who had the
privilege of paying $100,000 to get his
genome mapped today the same thing that
costs two point seven billion dollars 15
years ago or $100,000 five years ago
cost a couple thousand dollars and that
cost is going to continue to go down
what does this mean
it means two things it means we are
going to be able to diagnose illnesses
far far far far earlier and it means
we're gonna be able to develop precision
medicines first on precision medicines
right now if you get an illness you go
to your doctor and depending on what you
have he'll prescribe you one or two
medicines if you're fat you'll get a big
dosage if you're skinny you'll get a
lower dosage that's the personalization
in the future as in what I think will be
as soon as four or five years when we
get medicines they will be personalized
to account for our personal genetic
makeup as well as the specific genetic
makeup of the illness that we have and
what I think this this will do is it
quite likely will add a couple years of
expected life expectancy to all of this
it's kind of a big deal the second thing
early diagnosis of illnesses
I played rat I play racquetball every
now and then with this guy named Bert
vogelstein and when I first met Bert
vogelstein I thought he was in gym rat
sort of this scraggly old guy in his 60s
gray beard wears a knee brace over his
1970s style gray sweat pants
carts is racquetball gear to the court
in a dingy old Samsonite suitcase
turns out Bert is the most world's is
the world's most sighted living
scientist he's dr. Bert vogelstein from
Johns Hopkins University and some 30
years ago he and his team of researchers
determined how mutations and proteins
cause cancer kind of a big deal so now
Bert and his team of researchers at
Johns Hopkins have developed something
called a liquid biopsy and what a liquid
biopsy does is it takes a blood sample
you know just like we get at our annual
checkup now testing for things like
cholesterol levels and whether you've
got an STD and in that blood sample they
can detect cancerous cells at 1/100 the
size of what can be detected by an MRI
what does that mean it means that
cancers that are routinely found in
stages 3 & 4 and which are more likely
than not fatal will be will be found
early in stage one where cure rates are
far far higher this is another life
expectancy changer this is another thing
that is going to add years to many
people's lives
you